hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at the scandinavian
offense which starts out with pawn to e4
black responds pawn d5 and white
capturing on d5 and there are two main
lines that you'll see from black and
those are the ones we're going to take a
look at today the first one is Knight to
f6 and the second one is Queen to d5 and
we're going to go over the main lines
for both of those and talk about what
both sides should be thinking about when
they play that first one that we are
going to look at is the less common and
that is 90 to f6 attacking the pawn here
on d5 but not taking back immediately as
you would with Queen to d5 and he would
do this for two reasons one is he want
to get to upper hand and development
with very active pieces or he may think
that he just is going to get that pawn
in a few moves it really depends on how
white plays in response to 90 to f6 and
white has a few different things if
white wants to hold on to this extra
pawn which a lot of players do y can
come down to pawn to c4 holding on to
this pawn on d5 now black has a few
options from here the most common that
you'll see is playing pawn to c6 this
kind of has a comic on defense to it but
if white captures on c6 black can take
with his knight on c6 he has two very
active Knights he has great development
he has great student control even though
black is down upon he's actually in very
good position here and has good
compensation for the pawn that he's down
more common that you'll see after pawn
to c6 is white moving pawn to d4 giving
back the pawn that we can take on d4 if
he wants to capture but as you can tell
here we've given back the pawn advantage
but the development is about the same we
can now develop our Knights and black
does not have a development advantage or
a center advantage that he had before
when we captured on c6 so you may see
this another thing you may see instead
of playing c6 after we play see for
Black has the option of playing e6 which
is the Icelandic gamete and after white
captures on e6 black can recapture on e6
with his Bishop and as you can see black
is down upon but all his pieces are very
active he has a developed Knight he has
a developed Bishop to e6 here and his
Queen has this open file he's attacking
this pawn on c4 and all his pieces look
very active where white really doesn't
look like he has many active pieces he
has a random pawn on c4 but none of his
pieces have moved anywhere this is
actually my favorite the Icelandic
gambit just because I like to play very
aggressive and this is a very aggressive
defense for black so that's what you may
see if they start out with c4 and they
try to hold on to it the white may not
always try to hold on to it the actual
main line is for white to play d4 giving
back this pawn on d5 knowing that if he
doesn't play before then black can get a
lot of spatial and development advantage
so many times you'll
see wipe lady for giving back this pawn
on d5 from here if black takes on d5
regaining them material back White has a
few options the first option is two
ideas one would be to place c4 first and
then black and choose if he wants to
play Knight to f6 which is very passive
you never really want to move your
knight back to the same square that came
from it's kind of a wasted move a lot of
times you'll see Knight to b6 as you can
see we're already starting to put a lot
of pressure on black that's one idea
another idea white may have is to first
play Knight to f3 and then when Bishop
plays Bishop to g4 pinning our knight
here then we can come in with our pawn
to c4 it looks better for black he has
his Bishop developed but now when he
plays Knight to b6 we can actually
spring a trap on him and play pawn to c5
here now he has three options very very
passive would be to put his night on c8
now his Knights aren't doing anything he
can also put it as knight on d7 and d5
d5 looks a lot more active than d7 but
if he does play d5 we can bring our
Queen to b3 and this is actually going
to be very good for us we're attacking
this
Pease here on d5 and at the same time
we're attacking the b7 square which is
our main target here
so this will be very good for white and
even if black plays Knight to d7 as you
can see black is already starting to
cramp his style and we can continue our
development we can even bring our Bishop
to e2 and then we can Castle kingside
but this is going to be completely fine
for white so another thing you may see
instead of Knight f6 is going to be the
main line and that is with Queen
capturing on d5 you're going to see this
most times than not from here the most
common move for white and what I
recommend is Knight to c3 and this says
two things one it develops your Knights
of c3 and they gains a tempo meaning
that black is going to have to move his
Queen because right now he's being
attacked and you never really want to
move one of your minor pieces or your
major pieces more than once in the
beginning if you don't have to obviously
Black has two right now since we're
attacking it but Black has a few moves
here his worst move I would say out of
the three that people play would be
Queen to d8 this is just a super passive
move why move your queen back to the
same square that it came from more
common that you'll see is a move like
Queen to d6 which is the Bronstein
variation or the main line is going to
be Queen to a5 it's a very active square
for the Queen if you're going to bring
your queen out more than likely you want
to keep them active no point putting him
back on d8 since that's where it came
from
there's nothing white can do right now
to kick this Queen out of the way one of
the key things that you want to think
about when you're white or black a lot
of beginners always have the thought in
their head if
is out they have to try to trap him
right away right away that's usually in
the stick if the Queens out what I
recommend is just develop your pieces
like normal if you're going to trap a
queen you're going to be able to trap
the Queen once your pieces are developed
you're not going to be able to trap a
queen with one developed piece out so
first develop your pieces and then if
the Queen is still out there then you
can start looking for a trap but too
many times players fall into a trap of
their own because they try to chase
around the Queen the next thing you know
they're down a rope or they're
checkmated all because they were chasing
around a queen just develop your pieces
like normal
once your pieces are developed and you
have King safety and the king and the
queen is still out then go after but not
before it's just a huge mistake
from here white can play pawn to d4
again simply developing his pawn to a
great square and from here a lot of
players that play black this game Navy
in defense they really it's kind of a
variation of the Cara constant from here
black will normally play pawn to c6 the
car work on defense and from here
White's going to continue simply
developing his knight to f3 good
development square putting pressure on
the center from here you may see black
move Knight to f6 good development
Square from here blacks going to take
center control with his Bishop to c4
from here you may see black may even put
his Bishop on g4 pinning our knight down
that's fine or you may see Bishop to f5
very good square putting central control
and then from here Bishop to d2 getting
ready to castle moving his queen
correcting the rooks normal opening
procedure and then from here blacks
going to continue with pawn to e6 and
most players to play Comicon like to
have their pawns on c6 and ecigs
definitely would like to have their
Bishop out before they do that you don't
want to block your bishop in first and
then it takes on a normal play of a game
anytime white wants to start attacking
this Queen the Queen can always retreat
to square like c7 if he needs to
depending on if the file is open here
you can always come back to d8
Black's going to have a fine game why
it's going to have a fine game it's
really going to come down to the middle
game here but as you can see this Queen
that came out early it's not really
doing anything yeah it's a pain that we
have to worry about it but it's not
really attacking anything and it white
can try to kick this out but black after
the c6 play has a very good outpost that
you can bring his queen to so these are
some of the common things you'll see in
the Scandinavian defense hope you guys
learned a lot if you haven't already
please subscribe hope you guys enjoyed
I'll see you guys next video thanks for
watching